- A talk on a project to look at
dementia and developmental disabilities,
from two individuals from
the Arc of San Francisco.
Jennifer Dresen, who's the Chief of Health
and Housing Services, and Joanne Rolle,
who is the Chief of Services,
Outcomes, and Compliance.
(applause)
- Good afternoon; excuse me.
Really happy to be here
today; I'm Jennifer, Joanne.
And we're going to be talking to you today
about our experiences and partnership
with other expert
organizations in their field
to improve outcomes for our clients.
And, before we start,
I'd like to give a thanks
to Kristin Raines, who is our
Community Support Coordinator,
for the project that we are
going to be talking about,
and she put a lot of
work into this PowerPoint
along with us.
So I just wanted to give
her a little shout-out.
I have to ...
- (mumbles)
- Ah ha, there we go, thank you, okay.
So we have no disclosures.
All right, so after
the presentation today,
we hope you have learned
how we have leveraged
our expertise among partner organizations,
the prevalence of dementia
in adults with IDD,
how dementia looks different
how to provide support to adults with IDD
and dementia, and their caregivers.
We'll provide you with some resources.
- Just a little bit about
the project background.
In 2016, the San Francisco Department
of Aging and Adult Services,
also known as DAAS,
applied for a federal grant
from the Administration
on Community Living
to reach underserved communities.
The Alzheimer's Association
wanted to access
and serve the Chinese community,
persons living alone in public housing,
and adults with
developmental disabilities.
The Arc partnered with UCSF
to provide dementia evaluations
of adults with Down syndrome,
both as experiencing symptoms,
and adults who are asymptomatic.
We also reached out to
Golden Gate Regional Center
to offer training and support to staff,
vendors, paid caregivers,
and family members.
Due to improved health
care, social services,
and a decrease in institutionalization,
people with IDD are living
longer and more fulfilling lives.
According to a 2015 report
by the Coalition for Compassionate Care,
in 1940, the average lifespan for a person
with intellectual and
developmental disability
was just over 20 years.
By 1960, the average life
expectancy had risen to 30 years.
Today, the average life
expectancy is 65 years,
just five years below
the general population.
For adults with Down syndrome,
the average lifespan is now 56.
According to the CDC, there are
approximately 650,000
adults age 60 or older
with intellectual and
developmental disabilities
living in the United States.
This is projected to double by 2030.
As our clients age, they experience
the normal aging process,
including Alzheimer's disease.
The Alzheimer's Association is correct
in reaching out to the IDD community.
We need to be prepared for that,
and we need knowledge to
serve our community well.
This is how we've partnered
to serve the IDD community.
These are the project partner roles.
So the Arc San Francisco is working on
expanding the target audience.
We work with other IDD
vendors in reaching out
to expand training, and the trainers are
the Alzheimer's Association staff.
And UCSF provides
evaluations and assessments,
and DAAS provides
monitoring and reporting.
So the Arc's role in the partnership
is connecting with the
other IDD organizations
about the need to increase awareness
of Alzheimer's and related
dementias in the IDD population.
The Arc San Francisco
is the largest provider
of IDD services in San Francisco,
and we work closely with
other organizations.
To work with other IDD organizations,
to be open to learning about receiving
cross-disability training as it relates
to Alzheimer's disease
and related dementias.
And I have to say, the
IDD community's been
very open about wanting more education
about Alzheimer's and related dementias.
And we work to educate the
Alzheimer's Association
on the nuances of
navigating generic supports
in IDD for better outcomes.
Providing education and advocacy
to existing resources
about how people with IDD
and their caregivers are best served.
We have a somewhat complicated system
that is difficult for those
unfamiliar to navigate.
We review this with our partner
and provide education about this,
but most importantly,
we open a relationship
and extend an invitation to ask for help
when needed from our community.
- So what's the Alzheimer's
role in the partnership?
First, to inform the
community of IDD vendors
of the statistics around
Alzheimer's disease
and related dementias,
particularly the prevalence
among adults with Down syndrome.
And as you saw in the previous slide,
we have a large number
of aging individuals
with IDD coming down the pipeline
that the IDD community needs
to be better prepared to serve.
Also, the Alzheimer's Association is
to deliver the trainings to professionals
and caregivers in the community
on recognizing signs of dementia,
needed environmental modifications,
and support strategies.
They're also developing a support model
for caregivers for us.
So where has this led us?
Well, it has led us to
belief and understanding
that the intersection of
our two organizations,
expertise and knowledge will lead us
to the best outcomes for everyone served
by the organizations,
that we need to take a
holistic approach to services,
and expand one another's knowledge base.
And while the IDD community
is in the best position
to serve individuals with IDD and ADRD,
our supports need to be
informed by the experts.
And a good example of the intersection
of our services or our belief systems
is that both partners really believe
in the ability of an individual
to age in place, as long as they have
the appropriate supports for themselves.
So what we've discovered so far.
Well, it's been an education
process for both parties.
And one of the most important
things that we've learned
is that the existing model
for the ADRD community
and their caregivers does
not seamlessly translate
to the IDD community and their caregivers.
There are fundamental differences
between those providing caregiving
for those with IDD and those without IDD.
And so we're going to
look at the differences.
- Okay, so those differences
for the general population
with ADRD is that they have,
most of the time, live-in caregivers.
In the IDD community,
we have somewhat readily
up to wrap-around services,
so we have a lot of
people receiving services
from family home
agencies, board and cares,
ILS services, independent living skills,
and supportive living services, SLS.
In the general population for ADRD,
there's traditional family relationships.
For the IDD community,
there's surrogate family relationships.
For the general population for ADRD,
there's a loss of independence.
For IDD community,
there's transitioning away
from a lifetime of encouraging
independence for people.
For the general population for ADRD,
there are new caregivers
for somebody with ADRD.
For the IDD community, there's
a lifetime of caregiving.
For the general population of ADRD,
their service model is "You come to us".
And in the service model
for the IDD community,
we go to you.
And then trainings for the
general population with ADRD,
they're designed for large groups.
And for the IDD community,
trainings need to be small-scale,
as services are intended
to be individualized
and we need to reach everybody.
We need to reach people in
board and cares, and FHAs.
- So given these differences,
where are we now?
Well, we realize that
training is critical.
The question is, who needs to be trained?
We have learned that we cannot
reach traditional caregivers
in the IDD community if they're not able
to identify Alzheimer's
disease and related dementia
and lacks awareness of the resources.
We know that professionals
are the gateway to families
and individuals in need of support.
Paid caregivers are supporting
older adults, many of whom
have lived in their board
and care homes for decades,
and have surrogate family
relationships with them.
So where we landed is, we need to adapt
the current support model in order
to meet the needs of the IDD community.
- So what we'd like to present to you now,
and this is a work in progress,
are some of the adaptations
that will be needed
to make trainings most
relevant to the IDD community.
The Arc provides a bridge to this as
sometimes we need to make it easier
for people to access our information
as we manage very complicated systems.
Not wanting to make people
research two systems themselves,
helping them by building
the information for them
and bridging the gap for them.
That's the Arc's role in this project.
Most people with IDD parallel
the general population,
with approximately 6% having
some form of dementia.
However, folks with Down
syndrome are a much greater risk
of dementia, due to the
extra 21st chromosome.
It is the 21st chromosome which carries
the greatest genetic risk factor
for Alzheimer's disease
in the general population.
Therefore, people with an extra chromosome
are at an even greater risk.
Approximately 50% of
people with Down syndrome
will develop Alzheimer's
disease by the age of 60.
They also show symptoms
at a much younger age
when compared to the general population,
with some people experiencing
symptoms in their early 20s.
The earlier the onset, the
faster the progression.
- So what is dementia?
Dementia describes a group of symptoms
which can be reversible or progressive.
It is diagnosed by a significant change
in two of the five categories:
memory, language, executive function,
perception, and behavior,
but it's very important to remember
that many individuals
in the IDD population
are already impacted in those areas.
Alzheimer's disease is the
most common form of dementia.
It's a progressive,
degenerative, and irreversible
loss of brain cells and neurotransmitters.
For the general population,
there are standardized tests
that can inform a diagnosis
of Alzheimer's disease.
However, for the IDD population,
these tests are not as effective.
Persons with IDD must be compared
against their own baseline, as they start
at a different capacity
than the general population.
So let's see what that looks like.
We often see the 10 warning
signs of Alzheimer's disease,
and this is from the
Alzheimer's Association.
So, for example, number one,
with the general population,
it's assumed that most people have
pretty standard memories,
so you're looking
for memory loss that disrupts daily life.
In the IDD community, someone
may have poor recall already,
so you're looking at new memory loss
that affects their daily life.
The same thing with number five.
General population pretty
much has a good grasp
on visual images and
spatial relationships,
but someone with an IDD may
not, and so you're looking
for new troubles in this area.
So how's a person with IDD diagnosed
with Alzheimer's disease?
Much in the same way as
the general population,
namely, review of medical records,
interviews with loved
ones, and assessments.
There are some early
warning signs to look for.
Behavioral changes, such as
getting lost or misdirected,
being confused in familiar places,
exhibiting new memory problems,
difficulties with gait and balance,
changes in visual perception,
changes in personality,
and sometimes late-onset seizures.
However, not all changes
indicate the onset of dementia.
Common causes of decline not
due to Alzheimer's disease
include psychiatric
disorders, sensory impairment,
musculoskeletal problems,
and medical conditions.
Other health problems that can also mimic
signs of demential include
dehydration, fractures,
urinary tract infections,
adverse drug reactions,
and dental or mouth pain.
It's important that these
be considered and eliminated
as potential causes of
any observed changes.
- Caregivers also need to be keenly aware
of how the environmental factors
can impact an individual's
level of functioning.
For example, a change in caregiver,
a change in staff, change in program,
a move, a new roommate, or
their favorite market closing,
all these can cause a person
to withdraw, become depressed.
Good team communication can alert members
to changes in their routine
which are causing the
client emotional distress.
So, if the signs are difficult to judge,
how is someone with IDD diagnosed?
The process of making a
diagnosis of Alzheimer's disease
in someone with IDD is the
same as making a diagnosis
of Alzheimer's disease with anyone else.
Diagnosis is based on a detailed history
of progressive change over time
in thinking, memory, daily living skills,
a physical examination,
tests of thinking and memory,
and investigations to
rule out other causes
of decline in functioning.
In order to establish a baseline,
it is recommended that individuals
with Down syndrome in particular
have a professional
assessment of communication,
memory, and other thinking skills,
preferably in their 20s, with a caregiver
who has known the
individual for many years,
and performed by a
professional with experience
working with people with Down syndrome.
If a professional
assessment is not possible,
it is helpful to have copies
of educational assessments,
speech and language assessments,
and psychological evaluations
to establish a baseline.
The Arc is looking into assessment tools
administered with the IDD population,
and we've done a lot of work
with other organizations
that have worked with other
Alzheimer's organizations.
- So, in this partnership thus far,
here is what we have to offer.
First, in January 2018, we started
a call-in support group for caregivers.
It is from 6 to 7 p.m. on the
third Thursday of the month,
so I guess we have had two now.
We've offered the
Alzheimer's Care Academy,
and that is a three-hour training
which provides an overview
of Alzheimer's disease
and how to care for an
individual with dementia.
To date, we've trained
over 150 professionals
and direct caregivers, and those include
day program staff, regional
center case managers,
board and care operators,
FHA administrators.
We also just started offering
the Adapting to Alzheimer's disease,
and this is a six-hour
training over three weeks
which provides a more in-depth training
with opportunities to practice
their newly-acquired caregiving
skills in between classes.
Our first class began on February 16th,
with eight people in attendance.
And it's really the
Alzheimer's Care Academy
and Adapting to Alzheimer's
disease training
which is still evolving,
because what we've found
is that, for the
professionals coming to this
three-hour training, they're wanting more.
It's not meaty enough.
And the Adapting to
Alzheimer's, it needs to be
more directed towards
the actual caregivers
that we're seeing now with our population.
It's the paid caregivers,
the surrogate family members,
it needs to be more modeled to them,
versus a live-in family member.
We're talking about people
who work different shifts,
they're not working with
the person every day.
These are the things we're trying
to incorporate into the training,
so we have something that's more robust
for the professionals and
caregivers for our population.
We also are offering, in partnership
with the UCSF Memory and Aging Clinic,
we can make referrals for
evaluations for dementia,
and we've referred three people so far.
And we're also in partnership with them,
hosting them to offer baseline screenings
for individuals in their 20s and 30s
who are not experiencing
symptoms of dementia,
but would like to have a formal
record of the adapted skills
for future reference should they arise,
and that's a voluntary program.
We haven't started it yet, but
that should be starting soon.
So, how do we support
someone with dementia?
There are adaptations to environments
and caregiving styles that can reduce
agitation, wandering, and confusion.
For example, adapting
the caregiver's routine
to allow for more respite
and support staff.
Also, adapting the client's routine
to a modified schedule
which reduces opportunities
to wander or become confused.
A big takeaway that I think
a lot of us have gotten
from the training is adapting
one's communication style
to say "yes" to every question,
regardless whether the
request is reasonable or not.
So someone, I think this is a big example
we see a lot, if someone
you're working with
a 70-year-old individual,
and they want to go
say "hi" to their grandmother,
go to their grandmother's
house, you just say,
"Yes, that's great; let's go do it."
Adapting the environment to make it easier
for individuals with dementia to recognize
important rooms, such as the bathroom,
while eliminating the confusion
of mirrors or shiny floors.
- Okay, resources that are available.
The National Task Group on
Intellectual Disabilities
and Dementia Practices, the NTG,
is the expert in the subject
and a rich resource on the topic.
They offer a number of publications,
training, and resources,
including early detection
screen for dementia.
Many of their resources are free.
The Alzheimer's Association
is another excellent resource
for training and referrals
to programs and services.
And, of course, the Arc San Francisco
has a number of services
available for free
to anyone in the Bay Area.
Our call-in support group
is available to anyone,
regardless of their geographic location.
Finally, your client's doctor may be able
to refer you to a number of resources,
including visiting nurses,
medication, and palliative care.
- And those are just a
few additional resources
where you can find more
information; thank you.
(applause)